hello belief nation today I'm going to
talk about seven ways and you can get
started with zero dollars so we get a
lot of questions recently from people
who are trying to start a business and
are trying to get funding and they feel
like they can't get started until they
have the funding to the law works out
and then they never make any progress
from lint among their business and I'm
here to tell you that I hate spending
money until I'm making money it's
totally possible I'm going to share with
you seven ways and you can get started
without spending any money on your
business so you can start making it
so the number one way is start with a
service so many people feel like they
need to have a product like how can I
start a business until I've ordered my
product and I have something to show
people an easy way around it is start
with a service start with a service by
going out and talking to customers
potential customers understanding what
their problems are understanding how you
can help them out a service business
isn't as sexy because it's harder the
scale because your trading time for
money and you don't want to do that as
an entrepreneur right I want to build
something really big and it's harder to
make a huge service based company but
what it does at the beginning of a
company is it gets you really close to
your customer right you really get to
understand what they need what they
don't need and it starts giving you cash
flow right if you have a certain runway
if you're doing this part-time and you
want to be able to quit your job or you
have put your job and you only have six
months left of runway before you're
going to run out of cash you need to
start making money as soon as you can
and the fastest way to do it is through
a service where you're connecting with a
customer the other plus is when you are
making enough money to support yourself
and you want to expand the product you
already have a customer base that you
can talk to and get their feedback on if
they would buy that product or not and
you have consistent cash flow coming in
from your customers so that it can
support your product development or that
maybe that first product doesn't work
out you need to go to a second one you
don't have to go back to get a job
because you have your service based
business starting it off for you it's
not the big glamorous fun thing to do
necessarily all the time and it may not
be the future vision of where you want
your company to go but starting with a
service over a product helps you get
started with no money and builds
momentum for your business
number two is use Facebook as your
website another common thing that I feel
entrepreneurs are writing to me asking
that they need money for is I need to
launch my website needs to be a great
website I need to have all my stuff up
on there and it's going to cost me
$10,000 or $5,000 or $2,000 or whatever
it is I need to get my website up before
I start my business no you don't start
on Facebook there's been a lot of
massively successful companies who just
started with their website as being a
facebook fanpage that shares their
information that has contact details and
there's been lots of business we've
started with no website at all and can a
website help you absolutely any kind of
marketing helps you but it's not worth
spending the money at the start you need
to be out there bringing in potential
customers making some cash first then
you can reinvest into your business if I
had to pick any social media platform I
would pick Facebook to be my website
that had my information a lot of its
laid out for you you don't have to be a
tech genius to figure it out you can
have your picture you can have your
hours you can put all your information
up there start with a Facebook page
instead of a website and as you start to
make money then you can transition to
building your own site and paying for it
my number three tip is go to them
another reason why a lot of
entrepreneurs want to spend money is
they feel like you need an office I need
an office an office is something that's
you know important and it represents my
brain and how we're going to have
customer meetings I can't ask them to
come and meet me at home easy way around
that is go to them write you want to
meet with them about their business
about their problems or what they're
going through go to their office it's a
great way to do it because you get to
see them in their setting you get to
understand them better they're
comfortable you get to see their
environment it'll help you make a better
judgment call and if you don't want to
go to their office or maybe they don't
have an office and we don't feel
comfortable in office
you didn't coffee shop you know I patent
office before I have this space here
trying to dance salsa all of my meetings
are still held at a Starbucks or a local
coffee shop I prefer it I like the vibe
of a coffee shop instead of being in the
formal offices so the first thing that
you do with your business is not go get
an office don't spend money on that
instead invest into the relationships
invested at the time and go meet them or
meet at the coffee shop and use the
money that you get to spend on marketing
and growing your business
my number four way to start without
spending any money is make alliances a
lot of people need to raise money
because they feel the need to go out and
spend it on marketing I need to take out
an ad campaign I need to spend on Google
Ads maybe not TV ads radio ads and
newspaper ads and flyers and business
cards and all the stuff in to go and
spend money on don't spend money on that
stuff you don't know if it's going to
work out or not and I hate the idea of
you dipping into your pocket and you
closing that window of how long you have
to make this business a success instead
spend your time to go out and make
alliance partnerships all it's going to
cost you is your time and your hustle
and your energy and not your dollars
find people who are already selling to
your target market
who are not selling what you sell your
service and go and connect with them and
see how you can make some kind of
arrangement and if you spent your time
lining up coffee meetings are going to
their office to have sessions with 20
the 30 to 40 people we're all potential
lines partners some of those are going
to work out and some of them are going
to be referring clients to you and now
you're in business and then the money
that comes in you can figure out if you
want to go and spend it on marketing and
business cards and websites and all this
other stuff but don't start spending on
that until it comes in and the easiest
way to grow business is through
alliances the people who are already
selling to your target audience find a
way to partner up with them not that
they own a piece of your company but
just a way to pass business to each
other if you do a good job servicing
their clients it's a win for them think
about who people are buying from before
they buy from you or after they buy from
you
what's the cycle of a product or service
sale before or after they buy from you
and who are they buying from who are you
sandwiched in between go talk to all of
those people and it's way easier having
a partnership kind of conversation and
alliance conversation then a sales call
for those of you who are afraid of
picking up the phone and talking to
customers it's way easier to talk about
a potential alliance partnership and how
you may be able to work with each other
then a sales call to a customer so it's
easier it's less stressful and the
chance of you becoming a success are
much higher because it's the fastest way
to grow your business and it doesn't
have to cost you anything
my number five way is getting noticed
I'd be using all of the free tools that
I have at my disposal and my hustle
heart energy and drive to get people to
pay attention to me and get my name on
people's radar and so you can use social
media right you can be posting from your
own accounts you can be connecting with
people who already are known in your
community so that you're part of their
community and you get to connect with
them you get to share their their advice
and comment if you're trying to sell
something that is to the Entre Nous you
want to connect with me you want to
leave comments on my facebook when I
leave comments on my YouTube you want to
tweet me up I should know who you are
right and not just selling me be part of
the community first respond to some of
the stuff that I'm putting out there
share your comments interviews below so
that you're a known quantity there are
some of the people who leave comments on
these videos that I know who they are
because they do it consistently and if
they ask me for something to review
their their product review their service
check out their website whatever it is I
would do it I would say yes because
they've already contributed a lot back
to me first so investing in that hustle
right you can connect with reporters
connect with the media write press
releases and again if a reporter has
covered your industry they need experts
look at every article that's written is
always an expert opinion on there the
reporter themselves they're not the
expert they're generalist they always
need that expert why can't you be the
expert for your industry if they've
written something before usually have
their Twitter at the bottom or their
email at the bottom connect with them
let them know what your thoughts are on
the subject if you're an entrepreneur
you should be an expert at what you do
so reveal that expertise and you're
making the lives of reporters easier as
well and so all of these strategies of
being on your own social media
connecting with other people on social
media connecting with thought leaders
and influencers checking with the media
and press releases all of that stuff
doesn't have to cost you anything except
your time your energy and your hustle to
get people to pay attention to
my number-6 way to get started without
spending money is to pre-sell so a lot
of people again feel like I need to
raise capital to build my product and to
get it out there and to build the
marketing and to actually create
something where now it's never been
easier to pre-sell and create campaigns
if you look at websites like Kickstarter
that are out there where you only
actually have to go out and produce
whatever it is you say you're going to
produce if you raise enough money to be
able to do it and now you can't just put
an idea up on Kickstarter and hope it's
going to take off the companies that do
the best the companies that raised
millions of dollars it comes that
achieve their goals are the ones that
are out hustling afterwards right you
launch your campaign you have to make a
beautiful video around it and again you
could you know ideally you're working
with somebody but if not you just do it
yourself then connect with the media and
connect with influencers and drive
people to that page so they're attached
to the mission what you're all about and
they love it and they want to preorder
it and if you don't get it you don't get
enough sales then you actually have to
go out and create that thing that's
going to cost you a lot of money part of
being an entrepreneur is constantly
trying to figure out how else can I do
this how can I be more resourceful it's
never about the resources you have it's
about the resourcefulness that you have
it's being able to do what you can with
what you have instead of focusing on the
things that you don't have and if you
keep focusing on those things you don't
have then you're never going to be the
success you're always going to have a
cop-out you're always going to have a
reason and you're never going to drive
forward on your path and so pre-selling
is a great way to do that before you
actually launch it to see if there's an
appetite for it so that when you do
launch it you have the money to pay for
it
and my number seven way to get started
without spending any money is to barter
is to trade think about the things that
you need to spend money on and find
people that you can make that kind of
connection with where you are trading
with each other so as an example when I
had sold my first business I was looking
to start something new and I wanted to I
wanted to have some office space right I
want to have office space with my own
rule
don't spend on office space so I made a
deal with a local venture capital
company where I got to be a part of
their operation I was helping bringing
deals I got a desk at their location
which was at Yonge new king for those of
you who know Toronto is one of the most
prestigious addresses that you can have
in the city it's right in the downtown
core and I got the office space for free
and as I started building up my new
company I had four to five the six
sometimes people working at that office
for free because I bartered because I
was helping bring in deals for that
business whatever it is that you feel
that you really need find somebody who
can provide it for you and figure out
what they want because money is a
currency but there may be something else
that you can do for them so you can
trade to get to where you want to go and
again it's about being resourceful and
not about the resources you have so
that's the summary of the seven things
that I think you can do to start a
business without having to spend any
money at all I'm curious what do you
guys think of the video what did you
learn from it what can you apply to your
company and then I missed some is there
an 8 9 10 that maybe should be on the
list leave it in the comments below and
I'm going to join in the discussion I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Allen Conway Allen thank you so much for
buying a copy of my book really really
really really means a lot to me
those are you watching if you want your
chance at a shout out in a future video
make sure to pick up a copy of the book
it's really good an email in your seat
so that we can keep track and see the
bonuses thank you guys so much for
watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon